wer ist eigentlich in der Politik ihr
größeres Vorbild haben uns im Vorfeld
gefragt Strauß oder Adenauer warum
Adenauer der berühmte Satz
was interessiert mich mein Geschwätz von
gestern naja das ist ja so ein Satz den
auch gern Moderatoren verwenden für sich
also ich glaube mal so es macht Nieren
Sinn in den Fußstapfen anderer zu laufen
deswegen aber Strauß ist natürlich für
für Bayern einer der ganz großen
Persönlichkeiten gewesen der über Vater
der CSU ich selber bin ja bei Edmund
Stoiber groß geworden
und ähm ich war generalsäge dabei
Stoiber Steuerberater Strauß das ist so
eine leicht geniologische Verbindung ist
da gibt in der CSU und im Interesse von
Bayern zu streiten das von beides super
gemacht und es versuche ich auch ja
verstehen wie finden Sie diesen satzauer
ist der noch aktuell nein aber ich
glaube einfach dass ich Mama die Zeiten
ändern ich habe jetzt wenn ich mal
überlege wie früher die osterwäsche
abgelaufen sind die Grünen vorneweg und
heute laufen die Grünen eher bei
Bundeswehr Militärparaden mit oder oder
wenn wenn ja raus Macher in neue
panzerserie vorstellt dann sind sie da
an erster Stelle dabei warum weiß ich
die Lage geändert hat ja das Leben
verändert sich ständig ich habe vor
wenigen Wochen gelesen dass die
scheidende finnische Umweltministerin
eine grüne sich besonders eingesetzt hat
für die Kernkraft in Finnland findet es
richtig und ich glaube die hat auch ein
sehr weiten Weg hinter sich die Lage
erfordert deswegen immer Sturm meint die
letzten 30 Jahre bleiben gleich der so
ist meine Überzeugung wird die
Herausforderung nicht meistens ist auch
der Grund warum sie dieses die Zeiten
ändern sich ist mir wirklich aufgefallen
sie reden wahnsinnig viel über Fleisch
und Wurst in den Wahlkämpfen warum ich
rede nicht über Fleisch und Wurst aber
ich stehe eben auch dazu dass die
Bandbreite der Ernährung muss ist selber
auch mal versucht Veganer zu sein wie
lange paar Stunden paar Stunden und paar
Stunden ja oder einfach mal überlegt den
Ingwertee zu trinken den sie da sehr
trinken wenn er unsere Alfons Schuhbeck
immer sehr propagiert hat wie Sie wissen
über Veganer
der Punkt ist doch nicht ob jemand
damals als Foodblogger waren sie
unterwegs und haben sehr viele Tipps
gegeben ich habe mir das angeguckt
griechischen Salat Schafskäse mit
Avocado also all diese dich jetzt ist
das Foto das war vor einem Jahr und wenn
man das mal vergleicht mit den Bildern
heute das Spektakel
subjektive
letzte Woche schaut ja super aus
deswegen gefällt sie auch
beim Metzgerladen gibt's wobei die haben
auch Salate gehabt
nein nein nein nein nein die guten
Metzger in Bayern
noch mal ein schöner von ihnen vom
letzten griechischer Salat schmeckt auch
sehr gut von einem tollen Lokale in
Nürnberg
warum es war auch die Zeit aber über die
Grünen gesprochen
nicht total enttäuscht haben die Gründer
sind in der Regierung aus meiner Sicht
eine große Enttäuschung die für viele
Wählerinnen und Wähler der Grünen weil
sie sich erstens total zurückgehabt
zogen haben in alte Ideologie Bastionen
sie denken nur an ihre alte
partei-ideologie weniger an das
Gemeinwohl der Bevölkerung ob das in
Energiepolitik ist und auch bei so
Grundsatzfragen also man merkt es ja
Tierhaltung soll reduziert werden um
Fleisch sozusagen aus dem Markt zu
bringen in den Münchner Kitas haben die
Grünen durchgesetzt dass keine Wurst
kein Fleisch kein Fisch mehr angeboten
wird und das da wird schon ein kleiner
Kampf darüber geführt Angeboten
gibt
ich musste Nachfragen nein ich habe von
mir gesagt nein nein das ist ja also es
ist so also die Kinder dürfen
essen ja daheim schon natürlich
selber mitbringen
ist eine Grundsatzentscheidung ich finde
im ein Prozent Pfanne wir haben 7%
Vegetarier finde ich alles gut aber
diese
umerziehungswünsche die es von einigen
gibt die lehnen wir halt ab und ich
finde das selber darf ich zu Ende
entscheiden was er ist und was er will
und da brauchen wir keine also ötzte mir
das sagt will jetzt Süßigkeiten Werbung
verbieten es entscheiden doch die Eltern
und nicht der ötzte mir gleichzeitig
wieder Drogen einführen was der falsche
Weg ist das ist das was bei den Grünen
nicht stimmt und ich glaube auch relativ
dass es die große Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung so sieht ich finde damit so
lustig dass man über Drogen lacht
ehrlicherweise denn das finde ich na ja
schauen Sie ich finde auch ich trink
selber was denken kaum Alkohol wenn ich
ein Bier Anstoß dann nehme
ich glaube da haben sie ihre alten
Klischees über Bayern die aber natürlich
ja aber wenn nicht führen was die alles
so sagen wahrscheinlich sogar was was
jeder mal geschrieben hat wenn ich das
so sagen darf
vielleicht aus der Zeit geboren fakt ist
auf jeden Fall dass aus meiner Sicht ist
ein vieles Drogen zu legalisieren und
sein falsche Ansatz ist Eltern zu
verbieten die Ernährung ihre Kinder die
letzte Woche hier sehr hart mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister gesprochen und
diskutiert und ich ich bin da auf sich
um Fieber Säfte für Kinder nicht zu
kümmern oder zu wenig und Drogen zu
haben 90 joints im Monat ist diese
Regelung kommt das geht doch einfach die
falsche Richtung andere Probleme als
jetzt in der Frage er Drogen zu erlauben
das mit dem Alkohol würden sie trotzdem
nicht angehen nein das ist nicht also
dafür auch keine Debatte wir leben auch
eine in der freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
mich stört und das ist was über den
Gründen
in Bayern
das tun wir alle unseren Beitrag dazu
leisten aber es geht ja jetzt zum was
anderes es geht um die Frage sollen
zusätzliche Drogen erlaubt werden wo
Ärzte wo Polizei wo selbst die EU
skeptisches ob das der richtige Weg ist
und 90 Joints pro Monat sorry wenn ich
das sage ist einfach der falsche Weg
Cannabis und Marihuana sind einfach
Einstiegs Drogen warum soll man die Lage
jetzt so verschärfen und wir werden
alles tun was uns rechtlich möglich ist
das ähm gerade fast untersagen
zusätzliche Drogen das heißt Alkohol ist
für sie der Droge ja Alkohol ist es auf
jeden Fall nichts was jetzt von vorne
rein wenn es nicht in Maßen genossen
wird gesund sein
ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ob gesund ist
wenn man fünf Liter Ingwertee trinkt
aber das ist ihre Entscheidung ja ist
richtig ja aber also aus meiner Sicht
ist es jetzt falsch Strom zu leben
und albern dass man jetzt den Leuten
sagt ist dass diese Idee
oder gar nichts nein ich habe nur gesagt
das ist ein Fehler ist Drogen und dazu
stehe ich auch glaube dass die große
Mehrheit der deutschen Bevölkerung ist
genauso sieht ja auch immer anders ist
die große mehr ich wollte gerade sagen
Bevölkerung ist genauso sieht da sind
wir schon gleich wieder bei der
Atomkraft und bei anderen
ich hatte bei den vielen Würstchen die
gezeigt wurden da da ist irgendwie so
unweigerlich die Extrawurst eingefallen
weil
Nürnberger bratwürdiglich besonders
empfehlen kann
genau ganz
mögen dann würde ich ihn besonders
empfehlen ja genau also das würde ich
mal ich weiß ich kann jetzt nicht wie
viele Würste das sind zählen aber ich
würde sagen drei Klagen einmal
Erbschaftssteuer einmal Solidarität
Zuschlag dann
Wahlrechtsreform also dann Atomkraft
verlängern in Bayern das ist alles so so
sind so Sonderwege wo man auch auf den
Gedanken kommen könnte dass das
insgesamt so in ihr in ihre Rezeptur
passt einzeln Wege zu wählen irgendwie
Mehrheit und und dazu kommt was die ja
genau was die Mehrheit betrifft da sind
ja auch sehr Umfrage geprägt glaube ich
sie schauen gerne darauf wohin sich was
bewegt und dann nach Fukushima 2011
waren sie der Umweltminister der gesagt
hat also wenn es nicht schnell mit dem
Atomausstieg geht 22 oder 25 dann treten
sie zurück dann haben sie sich noch vor
zwei Jahren doch sehr stark ja selbst
gelobt dass sie der Vorkämpfer waren für
den Atomausstieg in der ähm in der
bundeskoalition oder mit der
bundeskoalition so und jetzt ist wieder
genau das Gegenteil jetzt sind die
Umfragen bei so knapp 60 Prozent dass
die Bevölkerung da so ein bisschen
Bedenken kriegt aus der Atom aus aus der
Atomkraft auszusteigen und dann machen
sie es wieder andersrum ich glaube dass
das so aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls nicht
stimmt erst einmal die Tatsache ob ich
da zurückgetreten wäre nett was könnte
woher sie das wissen ich glaube das
hatten sie gesagt
ihr Eindruck und natürlich auch ihr Stil
aber das ist nicht so erste Frage bist
dieser zwei wir haben damals bewusst als
erstes abgeschaltet weil er nicht sicher
gegen Flugzeugabstürze was war damals
die Debatte und Fukushima war die große
Frage ob Ereignisse passieren können die
sozusagen für die Sicherheit extrem
gefährdet war der Punkt
damals nein nein sicher läuft seit 35
Jahren übrigens störungsfrei anders als
in der Ukraine wo ihr die
Bundesregierung der Auffassung ist super
wenn die weiterlaufen die sind ja sicher
wenn Sie schon mal da stehen haben also
nochmal zum Thema unklare unklare
Entscheidung ich habe übrigens als erste
in Deutschland seit in der Krise in der
wir sind macht es sind die Kernenergie
zu verlängern es war vor über einem Jahr
da die Bundesregierung gesagt und dann
gar keinen Umständen es brauchen nicht
es sei falsch dann hat man trotzdem
einen striktbetrieb gemacht weil es
notwendig war hat man es verlängert und
ich plädiere nur dafür und ist die
grundsatzposition solange eine Krise ist
und solange auch die Preise so hoch sind
ist es aus meiner Sicht falsch aus
ideologischen okay und am Ende alten
Positionen heraus etwas abzuschalten was
uns helfen können was die ganze Welt
weiter nutzen ja also ganz kurz also ich
habe versucht gerade meine Erinnerungen
sie haben damals nicht gesagt wenn wir
nicht aussteigen dann trete ich zurück
das habe ich nicht gelesen gesagt
Konsequenzen gesprochen
genau und ich war nicht das Einzige der
das sozusagen als Rücktritt Drogen
verstanden hat offensichtlich auch
Christina Dunz und auch viele andere und
interessanterweise das ist so eine
klassische Journalisten Legende und der
eine erzählt dem anderen was allgemein
so mitgegeben und sagten der steht ja in
der Ukraine vor saporicia von dem großen
Atomkraftwerk und sagt ist doch super
wenn die laufen das hat er nicht gesagt
sie haben gesagt das ist super wenn die
laufen das hätte er gesagt es ist
Quatsch nein einfach Quatsch Robert habe
gesagt in der Ukraine ist okay wenn sie
laufen nicht gesagt doch weil sie da
schon mal da sind so ja und es hat
übrigens glaube ich auch die Mehrzahl so
verstanden ja bist vielleicht auch auf
einige wenige es ist doch teuerlicher
Witz bei uns auszusteigen Atomstrom aus
anderen Ländern zu beziehen und zum
Thema Sicherheit der u Menschen
Kernkraftwerke zu sagen na ja dann
laufen die halt dann sollen in
Deutschland
also ist jetzt der turmkraft so
gefährlich wie sie unter anderem 2021
noch gesagt haben oder nicht
Atomenergie in Deutschland ist sicherer
als in vielen anderen Ländern und als
ich die Frage dafür antworten was ich
für richtig sie sehen wollen dass Sie
die Frage beantworten sie Fragen was sie
für richtig erhalten da finde ich auch
manche Fragen ehrlich so ein bisschen
abstrus und vor allem ihre nachhaltiger
Meinungsfreiheit in dem Land also sehr
hier auch glaube ich eine freie Sendung
super sind ja auch mit großer Freude da
und das zweite ist ich sage ihnen was
sie für richtig halten richtig ist die
Kernenergie ist ist im Vergleich zu
vielen anderen jetzt der richtige Moment
um vorübergehend für einige Zeit ich
würde sagen für ein bisschen länger als
man die andere plädieren unsere Energie
und Stromprobleme und Netzstabilität und
auch die Strompreise zu halten ich bin
in der Sache total bei Ihnen trotzdem
noch mal die Frage
und dann finden Sie doch mal gut
tue ich doch es gibt so viele aber es
gibt so viele aber die Frage war nur ich
natürlich
meine Position ist die ja auch genau das
Problem
2021 ihre Position zur Atomkraft 2021
wir haben mal kurz rein ja es ist immer
Kernkraftwerke sein sicher es könnte gar
nichts passieren für mich war danach
klar Fukushima ändert alles ich habe
damals als junge Umweltminister sofort
reagiert mich mit dem damaligen
Ministerpräsidenten Horst Seehofer
abgestimmt und wir haben sehr schnell
entschieden dass wir bei uns in Bayern
das erste Kernkraftwerk in Deutschland
vom Netz genommen haben warum auch wenn
alles sicher scheint gibt es den nahezu
unwahrscheinlichen Fall die winzige
Möglichkeit dass etwas passiert und die
Folgen sind dann einfach in einer Form
dramatisch die nicht mehr zu akzeptieren
gewesen sind dieses Risiko
weiterzutragen
es ist ein schwerer aus der Kernenergie
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt auszusteigen eine
Energie und Technologie politische Sünde
und eine echte Gefahr für Deutschland
dass wir dauerhaft die Energieversorgung
nicht mehr sicherstellen können der
Weiterbetrieb wäre rechtlich und
sicherheitstechnisch absolut möglich
eins zu eins okay es ging damals um isa1
und das haben wir damals gemacht genau
das okay aber der kommt ja noch mal dazu
dass ich die Lage natürlich dramatisch
geändert hat wo fahren Sie mal eins zu
einsehen
also die Interpretation haben sie jetzt
hier wirklich exklusiv ja aber es machen
sie ja auch immer so sie machen ja auch
irgendwie in der Präparationen die 90%
ihrer Zuschauer zumindest eigentlich
gemeint übersetzen weil ansonsten könnte
man
also ist entscheidend
Aufgabe immer zu sagen das sagt jemand
was 2 + 2 = 4 habe ich übersetz mal er
meint eigentlich fünf das ist
natürlich als kritisch sehen
Zuschauer darauf hinweisen dass es nicht
meine Meinung ist sondern ähm ich glaube
in der jetzigen Phase immer ist gerade
zu abenteuerlich zu glauben dass Ukraine
nicht vieles verändert hat also man
sieht immer die einen fordern sogar vom
quiet mit Russland andere haben ganz
andere Positionen ich halte es mehr als
klug und für mehr als pragmatisch alles
zu überdenken und deswegen sind alte
ideologische Positionen falsch ich
glaube nicht dass du sie Kernergebnis 30
40 Jahre hilft da könnte noch andere
Energieformen stärker sein aber der
Ausstieg jetzt ist brutal von den Grünen
durchgedrückt worden und das ist aus
rein ideologischen Gründen der
Ersatzverkehr Energie ist in Deutschland
Kohle und damit erhöhen wir den
CO2-Ausstoß und eine Partei die sich für
co2-haft als Ersatz Kohle
jetzt so eng auskommen dann würde das
würde Bayern davon profitieren und eine
kurze Erinnerung
wie genau man etwas wiedergibt ich
glaube in ihrer Pressekonferenz vor zwei
Wochen als sie den Vorschlag gemacht
hatten mit der mit dem längeren
Laufzeiten speziell für Bayern da hatten
sie so einen Einsatz gesagt also
Gorleben Niedersachsen ist ja erforscht
für eine Milliarde ein sicheres
mögliches atommüllentlinger Endlager uns
ja genau das Gegenteil es ist ja
eingestellt worden ist überhaupt in die
Überlegung zu ziehen weil man gesagt hat
diese gesteinsdecke ist porös Regen kann
eindringen beim Salzstock weiß man was
dann passiert ist eben genau nicht
sicher und in dieser Pressekonferenz
haben eben so weggewischt und dann
denken alle ja meine oder manch einer
mag denken deswegen ist die Übersetzung
doch sehr wohl manchmal nötig war
vielleicht denken Mensch warum ist das
nicht in Gorleben aber es ist eben genau
nicht und dann haben sie noch gesagt
bei einem atommüllentl in Bayern würde
es ja nicht gehen dass sie quasi den den
Müll der anderen Länder aufnehmen aber
genau darum ging würde es gehen in einer
doch doch kannst du mir gerade noch mal
angefasst überzeugende Übersetzerin und
weiterdreherin also mal ganz kurz zu
Ende also das wer über längere
Laufzeiten wie sie nachdenkt muss
natürlich darüber nachdenken wo bleibt
der Atommüll haben wir ja bisher alle
bisher nicht geschafft uns darauf zu
verständigen in welchem Bundesland das
angesiedelt werden könnte aber wenn man
dann als einziger Ministerpräsident sagt
oder so stark wie sie sagt lassen wir
länger laufen dann muss man diese
Endlagerfrage klären und kann sie nicht
nach Niedersachsen schieben wo zumindest
dieses Lager oder Gorleben als Endlager
ausgeschlossen wurde glauben Sie mir
kurz nur drei bewegt das erste mal zu
dem Thema Stromtrassen wo sind denn die
Stromtrassen in Deutschland komplett
gebaut richtig wo sind die komplett
gebaut und wer baut sie momentan
die Bundesnetzagentur die Stromtrassen
sind in der beschlossen und vom
Bundestag danach wenn sie gebaut gehen
bei uns gut fahren ich unterstütze das
sehr allerdings finde ich gut dass wir
uns lange dafür eingesetzt haben
Erdverkabelung zu machen
ja aber da gibt es halt keine Einsprüche
und keine Klagen dann läuft das so
schneller ihre Bauern sind ganz schön
auf der Bühne
übrigens nebenbei merkt ich glaube wir
kommen sicher noch drauf wir haben es
ist jüngst sondern habe ich bestätigt
bekommen vom
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium wir liegen
bei dem Zubau erneuerbare Energien klar
auf Platz 1 mit Photovoltaik eine einen
Leistung
leisten
nein von 2000 fast 2000 Winterräder
das ungefähr die Leistung die wir mit
photovoltaikel genau
ja klar wir haben sehr wenig wir haben
sehr wenig Dritter wie Baden-Württemberg
übrigens aus alle Regeln geändert wir
bauen größere Windparks jetzt in Chemie
Dreieck Südbayern in für die
Glasindustrie in Oberfranken öffnen den
Staats komplett an der Stelle um da
entsprechend auch bei Winden erfolgreich
zu sein ich habe überhaupt kein Problem
mehr
sprechen bitte ja genau ich kenne keinen
Ministerpräsidenten in Deutschland der
sagt ich möchte eins haben nee aber
sagen auch nicht alle dass sie die
Atomkraft verlängert werden
soll das heißt wenn es einer gesagt
hätte wäre es schon geklärt erstens ich
fand es interessant dass man in diesen
ersten Untersuchungen sogar Städte wie
Hamburg oder München für möglich
gehalten hätte und nur Gott leben auf
keinen Fall und das dritte ist aber
meine persönliche Meinung ist wir
beteiligen uns an diesem Verfahren
übrigens der jetzige Atome lagert schon
bei uns mehr über 220 castorenbehälter
als Zwischenlage
aber wir haben hier wir nehmen uns dann
jetzt erzeugten eigenen Müll wie viele
Kalorien ich glaube 200 über 200 müssten
an den Standorten aber was ich viel
spannender findest die Frage wir müssen
parallel überlegen nachdem es jetzt
technologische Durchbrüche gibt
auch Reaktoren die möglicherweise den
Atommüll sozusagen verwerten so dass
keine entsteht sollten wir das
zusätzlich als forschungsoption sehen
weil ich finde diese Philosophie für
eine Million Jahre ein Lager zu
etablieren ein bisschen vermessen wenn
Sie denken was vor einer Million Jahre
war also ich bin da wirklich offen für
die Diskussion ich glaube dass wir gute
Argumente haben warum ein Standort in
Bayern wegen dieser prosität die Sie
ansprechen nicht geeignet ist aber die
das müssen
z.B unser Granit im Bayerischen Wald ist
aber ich glaube so nördlich der Donau
gilt doch alles als gutes prüfgebiet wir
haben auch geologische Gutachten gemacht
die sagen was anders also ich habe mit
Geologen heute wir haben heute noch mal
drüber gesprochen die sagten in Bayern
wird gehen
letzten Endes gehabt da haben sie mir
auch diesen Geologen aber keiner bei uns
kannte
mir nachher nochmal die Adresse von dem
Geologen kann man auch bei den Kollegen
lesen es gibt Gutachten darüber die
sagen Salz Ton oder Granit so richtig
die Tonschichten die bei Ulm Neu-Ulm
ungefähr sind der sind deutlich dünner
als andere Tonschichten in Deutschland
das heißt wenn sie wirklich dafür
plädieren dass wir neben der Suche das
soll jetzt übernommen zehn Jahre glaube
ich gehen oder elf Jahre gehen dass wir
uns parallel noch mal überlegen ob es
nicht noch eine andere Option für Atome
geht zumindest global gesehen wird es
eine neue Reaktoren geben die Atome
beseitigen Thema
glaube ich also
sagen ähm jedenfalls geht es voran und
gibt's da Möglichkeiten jedenfalls eine
Million Jahre halte ich für eine etwas
langfristige Planung ohne die Hoffnung
dass ich die Menschheit finde weil so
eine Millionen Jahren war hier an der
Stelle relativ wenig Mensch das Thema
ist ja eine Frage die man reden muss ja
klar würden sie so Lager machen wenn Sie
die entsprechende Gesteinsschicht hätten
ich finde es total faszinierend wenn man
wenn man
beteiligen uns daran glauben dass wir
gute Argumente haben nein
sehr gute Argumente sogar aber umgekehrt
Für dieses total spannend und auch so
ein typisches also von den beiden weiß
ich dass ihr das nicht sind aber ein
typisches grünes reaktionsmoment die
Grünen sagen sofort ja wer auch nur ein
Tag verlängert wollte der muss sagen
wenn man jetzt drei vier Jahre
verlängern da fällt ja nicht sehr viel
Atome an deswegen zu sagen soll weil wir
drei vier Jahre verlängern es soll
sozusagen als Strafe das Thema Atome
genannt werden das finde ich schon
ziemlich krass und ein bisschen
typischer
Süßigkeiten
50 Behälter oder sowas ich glaube nach
Bremen ist richtig im Kopf habe nach
Leben sind glaube ich 180 oder 110
Castoren wieder Aufbereitung
zurückgegangen in nach Bayern kein
einziger
wir haben ja auch überall in Deutschland
keine Regie gehabt nicht nur ein Bein
sie haben aber sie sind auf Platz zwei
in Bayern auch da sind sie richtig
spitze wenn es um hochstrahlende
Atommüll geht Niedersachsen Platz 1
Platz 2 Bayern Platz drei
Baden-Württemberg das ist die Frage wo
das gelagert wird war bislang für Sie
immer eine Frage wo Lagern das bei den
anderen nein aber Deutschland
auf Länderebene selber entscheiden ob
wir das weiterlaufen lassen und die
Frage sie entsteht daraus dann nicht die
Pflicht zu sagen eine gute lagern wir
das Zeug bitte auch bei uns ja das würde
ja nur für den neuen gelten nur nicht
jetzt für alle die schon wurde übrigens
war das ein Angebot an die
Bundesregierung letztes Jahr
hat Robert habe ich uns gesagt für euer
Gast also die österreichischen Speicher
die für uns dabei waren es könnte doch
selber machen
warum kümmert man sich der Bund ab und
der Gas eingekauft warum kümmert man
sich um alle nur nicht um uns der
Bundeskanzler hat es dann abgeholt hat
Unsinn macht er natürlich nicht wenn man
seine Bundeskanzler gewandt damals habe
ich ja gesagt also wenn ihr das so macht
dass ihr quasi uns nicht mit dem Gas
Unterstützung versorgt dann müsstet sie
gesamte energiepolitische Zuständigkeit
geben da war dann das Gespräch irgendwie
nicht so richtig fruchtbar mit habe ich
das war irgendwie unglücklich an oder
zickig oder wollt halt einfach nicht und
dann war das auch vorbei aber das war
der damalige Zusammenhang und äh
natürlich schon seit kleiner wie
Tschechien wie Slowakei wie Finnland
könnte es machen wissen Sie eigentlich
wie so ein Atomkraftwerk überhaupt
kontrolliert wird wie das wie das läuft
oder wer das macht die wollen wir
unbedingt Ministerin weiß ich das machen
fast ausschließlich Landesbehörden Bund
kommt ab und zu vorbei aber die
eigentliche Aufgabe machen die
Landesbehörden und deswegen könnten die
Länder das könnte auch Baden-Württemberg
wollen ich weiß es ist politisch nicht
gewollt und es geht halt auch nicht und
ich glaube das ist das noch in
Deutschland schwer vor die Füße sein
wird